I'm a big fan of the movie goon I mean I
know a lot of people are oh [__] that's
awesome dude I'm a huge hockey fan I've
played my whole life I play every Monday
night I have a friends who are in the
NHL I'm just I love hockey and
um that movie was I I know why everyone
loved it so much I know I became this
cult thing uh you know and thank you did
you you play you must have played hockey
no no no I've played baseball basketball
football all my a lot of my friends
played hockey but oh yeah because the
character's not supposed to really have
played hockey because you could see in
the movie I think he was supposed to be
a better skater though I don't think he
was supposed to be a hockey player but I
just remember when I met with Jay bear
shell and Evan Goldberg and Mike Dallas
um and I [__] lied hard I was like
yeah I can skate they're like sure you
just get like ah come on grew up in
Minnesota of course like it's gay oh my
God we get up to to you know two weeks
before we're supposed to start shooting
the the movie and I did um we had skate
you know camp
and then when they saw me and I was like
ankle skating I I don't even think they
were so nice to not even say like what
the [__]
like it just it I think there's just
like a quiet understanding of like oh I
guess we're gonna have to tweak the
character a little bit because the only
time I could stop is if I skated right
into the boards so then just
Incorporated that into the character but
it kind of worked for it I think but
those scenes like the scenes with it was
his name uh leave Schreiber
um just incredible you both like go toe
until you're such different
personalities in the movie but you're
both so tough and I buy it and there's
this just it's just such if you haven't
seen goon I don't know where you are